the gyro can experience oh it's so
exciting first of all we didn't even
tell you you got pewter yon vs. Jose
Aldo for your title just till feel like
yours I let it go again I let it go
honestly honestly I let it go and they
can they cannot kill each other that's
how I feel I'm so happy I'm so satisfied
honestly you look happy the point is
like what a division and that's unless
you cross me with something here I don't
know what you know I'm really excited
about that
Josie Aldo po2 yon fight but I'm it's
fascinating to me that they decided to
give the fight to Aldo even though
mirai's won the decision has a real
interesting choice isn't it because
although I agree with the decision I
think our excuse me I agree with Aldo I
think Aldo won that fight I think was a
really close fight but I thought Aldo
won the fight but it was close it was
really close but the fact that the
judges gave it to Marlon and then the
UFC is like nah player okay we're gonna
have Aldo fight peel and part of it is
because Aldo is obviously a huge draw
and one of the greatest of all time
particularly the greatest featherweights
of all time well you remember I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm actually gonna change your
mind on that it was actually it's really
my fault it's your fault
yeah it's my fault then Josie all those
fighting for the belt because that's who
I was originally supposed to fight with
Dominic but this whole coma thing
so although was gonna fight for the tile
and then it's like you can do that so
the UFC you know they stuck to their
word they gave oh that's interesting
still darling at least I think if Eddie
was here we could debate that makes
sense
100% makes sense that makes sense it
listen I'm happy for both fights I would
happy I'd be happy if Marlon fought
people to reach gone for the title or be
happy if Aldo fought him I'd be happy if
Marlon and Aldo fought again like
there's great fights in that division
now that you've stepped down really the
people that I think that should fight
for the belt would be a aljahmeir
sterling and computer or am i calling
Peter my either ain't gonna I'm gonna
get that off was it was it was Peter for
a while we're supposed to call Peter and
then they said no it's pewter pewter
pewter
it's like fade or you know fade or his
real name's not fade are it's fueled or
that's so rude we could have said fyodor
yeah but even somebody like Peter Yaman
like how dangerous is you really yeah
he'd be your ayah but your eyes been out
for a minute yeah I know besides Araya
who's what's have another big name that
that dude has beaten no well clearly
he's very good there's no doubt about it
whether or not he's at your level you
don't find out until he fights a guy
like you or he fights a guy like Aldo
that's when we find out what's up okay
we know he's really good you know the
way beat up Uriah is it's not just that
he beat him he beat him up and you know
your eyes is always gonna be a tough out
he's a tough guy man he's a super
skilled super seasoned guy your eyes
been around forever you know he's he's
fought so many good guys he knows how to
survive and CP order beat him up like
that it's like wow and he's [ __ ]
strong man he's [ __ ] strong like he's
got that weirdo Russian strength you
know he's got power he throws knees he
goes off the clinch yup yup dangerous
he's day he's technical when I see a guy
like that is like he's technical and he
has malice and what's almost technical
and a half of malice is like yeah that's
that's what I have you know what happen
and I can recognize yeah yeah malice is
a good way of putting it when Mike Tyson
would call bad intentions yeah yeah
that's he's got it
[Applause]